foreign
that geneticists use to understand
genetic information is to follow family
trees or to build what we call pedigrees
how a gene is passed on from one
generation to another by following not
only the information flow but also how
information is passed geneticists uses
as a tool to find the genes that cause
some traits
so for example in my own work we used
inheritance of a blinding condition
called glaucoma that was sorting in a
family in order to find the genes that
cause this illness in those families
really the question comes up how did
these different forms of a gene occur
the different forms of a gene occurred
due to the process of mutation mutations
are changes in DNA that are heritable
these mutations can occur through
mistakes made during copying of DNA or
they could be introduced by exposure to
chemicals the net effect is that DNA
gets changed as a result we get
different forms of genes that occur in
the population in addition to
potentially causing problems for an
organism such as a disease these changes
are also really the material that
Evolution works with to make environment
to make organisms better fit their
environment basically what happens in
the process of natural selection is that
organisms that are better able to use
and adapt to the environment leave
behind more offspring those that have
less beneficial genes do not leave
behind as many offspring and as a result
over time as this occurs again and again
and again we end up with
beneficial
traits which are encoded by different
forms of genes being the predominant
uh types of genes in an environment as
organisms are selected to fit the
environment the best
when Darwin went to the Galapagos he
noticed that
finches had different beaks sizes and
shapes even though they all descended
from the same Finch in this case beak
size and Beak style was selected to fit
the environment the best and so this
process Evolution acting upon natural
variation that occurs in a population to
allow organisms to better fit the
environment
is really the natural process by which
organisms adapt to their environments
thank you